und jetzt hoffe ich auf die
tagesordnungspunkte 18a und 18 b erst
die beratung des von der bundesregierung
eingebrachten gesetzentwurfs zur
weiterentwicklung der
gesundheitsversorgung sowie beratung des
antrags der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen mit dem titel mehr transparenz
und mehr anreize für eine bessere
versorgung wettbewerb der gesetzlichen
krankenversicherung für die aussprache
wurde eine dauer von 60 minuten
beschlossen nicht eröffnet die
aussprache und der teil des wortes
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn
[Applaus]
herr präsident lieber kolleginnen und
kollegen auslöser dieser pandemie ist
ein virus das unsere gesundheit gefährt
ist und eine unserer größten
sicherheiten in dieser pandemie in
dieser krise war und ist eine belastbare
gesundheitsversorgung ein robustes
gesundheitssystem das übrigens im
unterschied zu vielen ländern durchaus
auch nachbarländern zu keiner zeit
überlastet war
es ist stark belastet gewesen das ist es
in teilen deutschlands auch immer noch
auf den intensivstationen aber wir waren
jederzeit in der lage eben patienten die
notwendige behandlung zukommen zu lassen
und übrigens gerade auch wieder
gegenüber der tschechischen regierung
angeboten auch in der lage unseren
nachbarländern zu helfen
und wir haben in dieser pandemie in den
letzten monaten immer wieder akute
maßnahmen ergriffen um das
gesundheitssystem zu unterstützen die
vielen vielen millionen das arbeiten
über fünf millionen menschen in
deutschland im gesundheitswesen mit viel
leidenschaft aber vor allem auch viel
expertise um sie zu unterstützen in
dieser pandemie die krankenhäuser auch
aktuell ja mit rettungsschirmen um sie
abzusichern und da wird auch noch mehr
folgen müssen für dieses jahr um das
auch gleich klar zu stellen um sie
abzusichern in der pandemie den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst den wir
akut unterstützen in dieser phase auch
finanziell in der digitalen ausstattung
viele andere bereiche aber es gibt auch
unsere kontinuierliche und langfristig
angelegte arbeit dieses gesundheitswesen
in seiner struktur immer noch besser zu
machen und vorzubereiten auf die 20er
jahre
damit haben wir im übrigen auch schon
begonnen vor der pandemie in den letzten
bald drei jahren mit schwerpunkt pflege
die digitalisierung im gesundheitswesen
auf eine bessere versorgung insgesamt in
diese kategorie in diese perspektive
auch der langfristigen verbesserung der
versorgung ordnet sich dieses gesetz ein
wir sehen in dieser pandemie sehr gut
dass gute versorgung in der region
bringen kann sven krankenhäuser sich
vernetzen wenn sie sich zusammentun wenn
sie telemedizinisch zusammenarbeit der
gemeinsame bundesausschuss hat mit
unserer unterstützung auch nochmal
telemedizinische zusammenarbeit der
intensivstation mit blick auf q mit 19
beschlossen und das prinzip gilt es nun
auch natürlich weiter zu entwickeln für
die krankenhausversorgung insgesamt
misst dabei eins wichtig es geht nichts
wenn die diskussionen führen über
strukturen bei den krankenhäusern es
geht nicht um sparen oder schließen als
schlagworte die dann immer kommen es
geht um was anderes
es geht vor allem um qualität und um
eine gute vernetzte versorgung
es geht darum
es geht darum dass wir eine
grundversorgung in der fläche haben und
ich bin selbst münsterländer ich weiß
wie wichtig es ist dass ist gut
erreichbar kliniken gibt stationäre
angebote gibt vor allem auch für die
grund- und notfallversorgung und es geht
darüber hinaus eben darum schwerpunkt
versorger zu haben maximalversorger
unikliniken und das in einem netzwerk
miteinander wo in einer region nicht
jeder alles machen muss es muss nicht
jede klinik jedes krankenhaus
jede station haben da bin ich nämlich
bei dem thema qualität wenn sie etwas
nur dreimal oder auch nur 30 mal im jahr
machen das ist nicht nur einmal jede
woche dann ist das irgendwann auch eine
frage von qualität von erfahrungen von
strukturen gerade auch bei komplexen
operationen wenn sie in ein krankenhaus
kommen und die sagen so ein fall wie sie
hatten wir schon lange nicht mehr
da fühle ich mich nicht wohl wenn es um
was komplexes anspruchsvolles geht und
wir sehen dass tatsächlich das einen
großen unterschied gibt in der qualität
nur für die herren der prostata
operation gibt es bei denen kliniken die
die meisten operationen machen in
deutschland in dem bereich bis zu 40 50
prozent geringeres risiko für impotenz
oder inkontinenz 40 bis 50 prozent als
im schnitt
ich würde 1000 kilometer fahren wenn ich
wüsste dass das einen solchen
qualitätsunterschied macht und deswegen
ja es geht um eine gute versorgung in
der fläche
es geht vor allem bei komplexeren
planbaren eingriffen aber auch um eine
gute qualität für die patientinnen und
patienten
und deswegen legen wir in diesem gesetz
fest wenn sie dem zustimmen nach den
beratungen ist unser vorschlag
mindestmengen für bestimmte bereiche die
wir weiter auch die verfahrensregelungen
stärken qualitäts verträge als
instrument zwischen krankenkassen und
krankenhäusern die wir stärken wollen
für bestimmte bereiche um auch die
qualität eben in konkreten einzelnen
verträgen steigern zu können vor allem
aber transparenz dass der versicherte
dass der patient eben wissen kann und
noch besser als bisher wissen kann es
gibt ja durchaus schon transparenz aber
es ist manchmal schwer
transparenz ist schwer zu finden ist ist
keine wirkliche das ist manchmal schwer
nachzuvollziehen obwohl eigentlich alles
veröffentlicht ist wie die
qualitätsunterschiede sind und deswegen
ist es eben wichtig dass wir auch dort
einen weiteren schritt gehen
das ist ein wichtiger teil dieses
gesetzes der schwerpunkt es sind aber
weitere wichtige themen aufgegriffen
ich will nur einige nennen ein wichtiges
thema für die betreuung von menschen in
ihrer letzten lebensphase wenn es um die
hospiz und palliativ netzwerke geht die
wir stärker finanzieren wenn es vor
allem auch um die ambulante
kinderhospizarbeit geht die wir stärker
finanzieren wollen als bisher
es gibt weitere wichtige regelungen etwa
zur finanzierung der krebsberatung
stellen die für viele bürgerinnen und
bürger sehr wichtig sind weil sie eine
anlaufstelle sind die auch vieles
bündelt da geht es nicht nur
medizinische fragen da geht es auch um
rentenfragen um soziale fragen die wir
finanzieren strukturierte
behandlungsprogramme für die behandlung
von adipositas oder auch zur notfall
strukturen gibt es verbesserungen das
alles in viele punkte es sind viele
wichtige punkte für eine langfristig
solide versorgung weit über diese
aktuelle pandemie hinaus und daher
wünsche ich uns gute beratungen für
dieses gesetz
[Applaus]
also weiter entspannen der
bundesminister für gesundheit
nächster redner laut rednerliste zum
thema weiterentwicklung der
gesundheitsversorgung ist logisch und
von der afg mitglied im
gesundheitsausschuss weiterentwicklung
der gesundheitsvorsorge
der bundesminister für gesundheit hat ja
die wesentlichen punkte genannt worum es
jetzt hier in diesem falle geht der
präsident werde kollegen
ich muss mich jetzt mal lauten als ein
großer fan von qualitätsmanagementsystem
qualitätsmanagementsystem bevor besseren
prozesse abläufe und fehler als ich vor
jahren noch eine kassenzulassung hatte
war ich der erste in der region der eine
iso 9001 zertifizierung abgeschlossen
hatte und das war damals nicht
verpflichten meine damen und herren
diese haben wir dann auch erfolgreichen
anderer arztpraxen implementiert und
glauben sie mir
aus diesem wissen heraus kann ich ihnen
jetzt schon sagen dass es nicht möglich
sein wird gm systeme zwischen
krankenhäusern und arztpraxen
wirkungsvoll zu vergleichen wie es in
dem gesetzentwurf vorgesehen ist das
streben sie aber ein unter anderem diese
monströsen und unausgegorenen
gesetzesentwurf nicht nur das sie wollen
sogar die krankenhäuser und
vertragsärzte dazu verpflichten
das ergebnis ist ein völlig verzerrtes
bild das den patienten nicht hilft
sondern eher verwirrt die
patientenversorgung wird dadurch nicht
wie gewollt verbessert sondern deutlich
verschlechtert die fehler die sie mit
brachialer gewalt durch dieses
kühlsystem beheben wollen sind
grundsätzlich systemimmanent und ein
problem des gesamten gesundheitswesens
in deutschland
sie machen damit hier einen zweiten
schritt vor dem ersten und führen damit
das management selbst das eigentlich die
qualität verbessern soll ad absurdum
meine damen und herren ich empfehle
ihnen stattdessen dringend ein
qualitätsmanagement für die
bundesregierung einzuführen und vor
allem für das
bundesgesundheitsministerium wissen sie
auch warum dies würde nicht nur die
transparenz für die wähler erhöhen
sondern darüber hinaus auch das chaos
management der carola pandemie endlich
beenden
dann hätten sie der
bundesgesundheitsminister die drei haupt
werkzeuge des modernen crm systemen
genutzt nämlich erstens problemanalyse
entscheidungsfindung und drittens
lösungsfindung dann wäre uns in
deutschland in der tat dieses chaos und
der lockten komplett erspart geblieben
qualität beginnt nämlich zuerst mal vor
der eigenen haustür statt woanders
staaten schaffen zu wollen fakten
schaffen wollen sie auch bei den
haftpflicht ansprüchen der ärzte hier
sollen ärzte bei unterschreitung einer
gesetzlich vorgeschriebenen
versicherungssumme das ruhen der
zulassung drohen
wieso eigentlich denn in paragraf 21 der
berufsordnung der ärzte ist festgelegt
dass sich die ärzte hinreichend und ich
betone hier nochmal hinreichend gegen
haftpflichtansprüche aus der beruflichen
tätigkeit zu versichern haben eine
einheitliche mindesthöhe über alle
arztgruppen hinweg ist sowohl fachlich
als auch sachlich falsch dass sowohl
schadenshöhe als auch schadens
häufigkeiten in verschiedenen
arztgruppen deutlich variieren
möglicherweise droht hier ein verlust
der arzt zulassung in anbetracht des
ärztemangels ist es einfach nur eine
farce und absolut unnötig herr kollege
sparen wollen sie wirklich dass noch
mehr deutsche ärzte ins deutschsprachige
ausland oder gar nach übersee gehen oder
viele kollegen und spreche den aus den
herzen wollen einfach nur noch weg warum
wollen ärzte weg gehen weil all dies
inklusive ihres crm systems so weiter
und bürokratie monster und führt was sie
doch gerade nicht wollen sie
konterkarieren damit noch selbst
ihrem koalitionsvertrag in dem sie den
abbau der bürokratie verschrieben haben
und es wird sogar noch bürokratischer
und chaotischer in dem gesetzesentwurf
sie wollen bundesweit ein einheitliches
einschätzungs verfahren für die
ambulante notfallbehandlung einführung
dabei gibt es ja ein etabliertes und
langjährig bewährtes system an den
krankenhäusern will man hier aktionismus
vor glaube oder einfach nur eulen nach
athen tragen
wäre es nicht besser gewesen wenn man
schon was neues machen will
sie hätten ein integriertes notfall
system erschaffen indem ambulante
stationäre rettungsdienstliche und
katastrophen dienstliche
versorgungsbereiche als ganzes
abgebildet werden und daran wären
natürlich auch die vergütung
auszurichten
und wenn wir schon einmal bei der
verhütung sind wollen wir auch über ihre
tarife form bei der privaten
krankenversicherung reden
dort wollen sie den notlagen tarif an
den basistarif angleichen so weit so gut
aber ehrlich sollte man sich nicht viel
dringender wichtiger beim themen widmen
dazu zählen erstens dass privat
versicherte ihre altersrückstellungen
beim versicherungswechsel bedingungslos
mitnehmen können damit die versicherten
den beitragserhöhungen der
versicherungskonzerne nicht alternativ
ausgeliefert sind und zweitens sie
sollten darauf einwirken dass nun
endlich die gebührenordnung der ärzte
dynamischer und schneller sich den
aktuellen gegebenheiten anpassen kann
auch eine regionale komponente wie
beispielsweise in unserem php system
vorgeschlagen wäre durchaus vorstellen
meines wissens nach liegt seit 2013 dem
ministerium ein gemeinsamer vorschlag
der bundesärztekammer und dem verband
der privaten krankenversicherung dazu
vor seit 2013
dennoch lässt sich auch was positives
vermerken erspart denn sie haben es in
der tat geschafft den anspruch auf
vorsorgeleistungen in eine
pflichtleistung umzuwandeln
denn gerade im pandemie zeiten zeigt
sich wie wichtig prävention für unsere
gesundheit das gesundheitssystem und
insbesondere für unsere kurort medizin
ist
ich danke ihnen für die aufmerksamkeit
so weit apple schlund von der afg
fraktion erst gesundheitsexperte seiner
fraktion erst praktizierender arzt in
thüringen mitglied im
gesundheitsausschuss und es handelt sich
ja hier um ein sammel gesetz des
bundesministers für gesundheit und das
hat und als viel zu komplex oder in
seinen worten monströs bezeichnet
nächste rednerin sabine dittmar
gesundheitspolitische sprecherin der
spd-fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen mit der
heutigen ersten lesung beginnen wir die
parlamentarische befassung mit dem
gesundheits versorgungs
weiterentwicklungsgesetz kurz tv wg und
auch wenn wir in dieser
legislaturperiode schon viele gute
gesetze auf den weg gebracht haben so
zeigt der vorliegende gesetzentwurf dass
uns die arbeit nicht ausgeht wenn es
darum geht die versorgung der
patientinnen patienten weiteres stück
für stück zu verbessern
der gesetzentwurf besteht aus einer
vielzahl an regelungen die einzeln
betrachtet kein geschlossenes bild gibt
aber wie bei einem puzzle geht es auch
hier um das ende am ende um die noch
fehlenden teilen und ohne sie ist die
bisher geleistete arbeit geben
unvollständig und unser ziel ist es mit
dem gesetz liegt eine lückenlose bessere
versorgung der bürgerinnen und bürger
weiter ein stück weit zu regnen und ich
bin davon überzeugt dass im
parlamentarischen verfahren auch das
eine oder andere puzzleteil noch dazu
kommen wird meine meine damen und herren
ich komme aus einem wahlkreis mit fünf
heilbädern kissingen bad bocklet bad
brückenau bad neustadt bad königshofen
eines schöner als das andere
für die für die heilbäder und kurorte
ist es von enormer bedeutung dass
zukünftig ambulante und stationäre
vorsorgeleistungen wieder zur
pflichtleistung der gesetzlichen
krankenversicherung werden denn sowohl
als kreisrätin als auch als
praktizierende ärztin habe ich in den
90er jahren erlebt wie die gesamte
region gelitten hat als sie seehofer
gesundheitsreform die vorsorgekuren aus
dem leistungskatalog gestrichen hat und
es hat lange gedauert bis wir uns nach
diesem kahlschlag wieder berappelt haben
bis wir in einer langen
stadtsprecher uns zu einer etablierten
gesundheitsregion weiterentwickelt haben
wir heute gut aufgestellt ist und die
den neuen herausforderungen entgegen
fiebert mit dem für den vorliegenden
gesetzentwurf werden wir nun den zugang
zur ambulanten und stationären
vorsorgeleistungen verbessern
es ist nicht nur für den versicherten
und sein umfeld wichtig frühzeitig
anzusetzen und damit eine
chronifizierung von erkrankungen zu
verhindern
es macht einfach auch
gesamtwirtschaftlich und
gesellschaftlich sind die prävention zu
fördern und krankheiten gar nicht erst
entstehen zu lassen und die weiteres und
ein weiteres puzzleteil sind die
regelungen zur
berufshaftpflichtversicherung die spd
hat lange dafür gekämpft dass
vertragsärzte im sozialgesetzbuch
verpflichtet werden eine
berufshaftpflicht versicherung
abzuschließen und auch nachzuweisen und
mit einer mindestversicherungssumme von
drei millionen euro pro versicherten
fall können patientinnen und patienten
künftig darauf bauen dass ihre
berechtigten schadensersatzansprüche
tatsächlich auch bedient werden können
das sind übrigen auch eine forderung des
um des rechnungshofs meine damen und
herren wir werden wir dem gesetz auch
zwei weitere themen aufgreifen die uns
sozialdemokraten sehr wichtig sind zum
einen die einführung eines weiteren
strukturierten behandlungsprogramme
seines dmb adipositas und zum anderen
den ausbau des zweiteilung des
verfahrens zwei drittel der männer und
die hälfte der frauen in deutschland
sind übergewichtig ein viertel der
erwachsenen sogar stark übergewichtig
adipositas ist nicht nur eine krankheit
sie ist auf der wurzel und der
katalysator für für weiterentwicklung
von erkrankungen und deshalb ist es
sinnvoll
deshalb ist es sinnvoll und notwendig
die patienten in einem strukturierten
behandlungsprogramme zu unterstützen
mit dem mit dem tempel adipositas setzen
wir im übrigen auch eine forderung aus
unserem gemeinsamen an
nationale diabetes strategie um aber
sehr geehrter herr minister sparen der
antrag der koalitionsfraktionen erhält
noch viele weitere wichtige aspekte die
darauf warten dass sie tätig werden
darüber hinaus werden wir mit dem gesetz
den anspruch des versicherten auf ein
unabhängiges ärztliche zweitmeinung
verfahren ausbauen zweitmeinung
verfahren sind ein wichtiges instrument
um patientinnen und patienten bei der
entscheidung zu unterstützen ob
bestimmte planbare eingriffe wirklich
notwendig sind oder ob es alternativen
gibt ja und abschließend meine damen und
herren widmen wir uns in dem gesetz auch
der ambulante notfallversorgung wir
werden ein standardisiertes und
bundesweit einheitliches erst
einschätzungs verfahren für patienten
vorgeben
aber ich sage hier auch ganz offen ich
hätte mir im bereich der
notfallversorgung mehr gewünscht und ich
bedauere es wirklich sehr dass es nicht
gelungen ist mehr patienten steuerung
und mehr vernetzung zu etablieren dass
hier keine vereinbarung mit den ländern
und keine absprache mit den ländern
getroffen werden konnte
das bedauere ich sehr unter weiß wir
haben aufgaben für die nächste
legislaturperiode noch vor uns der auch
meine damen und herren das vorliegende
gesetz ist sicherlich kein großes
zentrales reformgesetz an denen wir uns
auch noch jahre später erinnern
aber wir werden in diesen zahlreichen
puzzleteilen dazu beitragen dass viele
spezielle bereiche in der ambulanten und
stationären versorgung ein stück weit
besser werden freue mich auf die
parlamentarische befassung und bedanke
mich für die aufmerksamkeit und bleiben
sie gesund das gesetz heißt langsam zum
mitschreiben gesundheitsversorgung
weiterentwicklungsgesetz die vwg soweit
sei wie nötig man die
gesundheitspolitische sprecherin der spd
zu diesem thema aus unterfranken standen
aus dem wahlkreis bad kissingen das mag
erklären warum sie besonders sich die
ambulante und stationäre
vorsorgeleistung in anerkannten kurorten
konzentriert hat wie sollen zur pflicht
werden leistungen umgewandelt werden
nächster redner andré kuhlmann von der
fdp herr präsident meine damen und
herren das spanische omnibus ist wieder
unterwegs
dieses klassische omnibus gesetz das die
vwg inhalten mehrere regelungen zu
qualität und transparenz in der
stationären versorgung spezifikationen
so völlig zu qualitäts verträgen
einholung einer zweitmeinung pkv
notlagen tarif erst
einstellungsverfahren für die ambulante
notfall behandlung in krankenhäuser
föhren koordination in hospiz und
palliativ netzwerken und vorführungen
von akademischen ausbildungsangebote in
der ergo logopädie und physiotherapie
das ziel ist unschwer zu erkennen die
leistungsfähigkeit der
solidargemeinschaft ist zu erhalten und
die versorgung qualitativ
weiterzuentwickeln
dieser bündel unterschiedlichster
gesetzliche maßnahmen beabsichtigt die
leistungen sowie die qualität und
transparenz der versorgung zu verbessern
netzwerke zu stärken und strukturelle
verwerfungen zu beseitigen
dieses ansinnen herr minister ist
grundsätzlich zu begrüßen
die erst auf schlafe mehr qualität in
krankenhäuser ist wichtig und gut und
längst überfällig ein weitere schritte
müssen natürlich schwer ist es ab
september folgen
wir reden leider zu häufig über
gesundheit als kostenfaktor statt über
versorgungsqualität zu diskutieren wie
wir dieses verbessert die dieses
verbessert werden kann
wir wissen alle welche druck
mitarbeiterin mitarbeiter in
krankenhäuser tagtäglich ausgesetzt sind
oder auch in den arztpraxen die
rechtfertigung warum welche medizinische
maßnahmen ergriffen werden und immer die
sorge von kaufmännischen direktion dass
die kosten nicht decken sind wir müssen
endlich diese spirale
durchbreche der kalte strukturreform
durch insolvenzen können natürlich nicht
die lösung sein
wir brauchen eine strukturreform hin zu
mehr qualität das bedeutet auch das
bedeutet auch dass nicht mehr jedes
krankenhaus jeden eingriff machen darf
die krankenhäuser die sich den eingriff
speziellen eingriffen spezialisiert
haben können es aber dafür richtig gut
denn übung macht den meister
wir wollen als fdp gute medizin überall
ambulant vor stationär und für alle
doch warnen möchte ich vor vier vor der
vor fehlender bürokratie entlastungen
oder wollen sie mehr bürokratie aber ein
bereich offensichtlicher eine entlastung
in denen es wert im umfang fehlt einige
beabsichtige maßnahmen beherbergen
nämlich die gefahr von neuen
bürokratischen verpflichtungen und
mögliche zusätzliche finanzielle
belastungen
da werden wir diese punkte noch mal
genauer in den anhörungen prüfen denn
wir wollen medizinische qualität aber
ohne mehr bürokratie drei aber manchmal
gesetzgebung sieht das anders aus
drei punkte möchte ich gerne
herausgreifen die ich noch bemerkenswert
finde frühzeitige vorkehrungen um
ausreichende menge an grippeschutz
impfstoffe für die wintersaison 20 21 22
zu besorgen halte ich für den richtigen
weg wir müssen wir uns auch gedanken
machen
aufgrund der entwicklung von coop 19
mutationen dass da möglicherweise auch
eine weitere impfkampagne stattfinden
muss und da bedarf es jetzt die planung
und nicht erst in ein paar monaten
zweiter punkt ist der aufbau und
förderung von regionalen hospiz und
palliativ netzwerken und das kann ich
als einer der sehr lange in der
krebsmedizin gearbeitet hat als etwas
ganz essentielles auch hier hinweisen
dass wir so etwas auch brauchen
der dritte punkt frau widmer hat es ja
gerade kurz angesprochen diabetes
prävention findet sich ein wenig
versteckt in den sogenannten
dieses management programm für
adipositas aber das ist auch ein
wichtiger und richtiger weg wobei ich
mich frage wie weit es nicht vielleicht
doch eher zur selbstverwaltung gehört
die stadt ist gesetzlich festzulegen
aber auch da werden noch anhörungen
stattfinden und das besser zu verstehen
ich freue mich auf das
gesetzgebungsprozess in der wik richtige
weg richtung für mehr qualität in der
medizinischen versorgung ist der
richtige weg aber fortsetzung müssen
natürlich folgen herr minister aber ein
fehler darf sich nicht wiederholen mehr
bürokratie herzlichen dank und andrew
ullmann von der fdp fraktion jetzt kommt
harald weinberg von den linken nächster
redner sprecher für gesundheitsförderung
und prävention wie in der
linken-fraktion die arbeit im
gesundheitsausschuss bzw in der
gesundheitspolitik arbeit waren wirklich
gehling einsammeln gesetz des
bundesministers für gesundheit steht
hier zur debatte wird gerade in den
bundestag eingebracht präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
gesundheitsversorgung 's
weiterentwicklungsgesetz 46 buchstaben
wer denkt sich eigentlich bei ihnen im
ministerium solche namen aus gibt's da
eigene abteilungen oder referenten die
das machen
alles wird immer weiter stärker schöner
besser herr brinkmann aber man hätte es
natürlich auch einfach sparen zur
resterampe nennen können nämlich
tatsächlich halt eben die rest bereiche
der kurs des koalitionsvertrages hier im
wesentlichen abgearbeitet wird es trifft
es recht gut weil das spektrum reicht
von mehr geld für obduktionen in
krankenhäusern bis hin zu verpflichten
eine berufshaftpflicht für vertragsärzte
wir haben's gehört mehr als 35 einzelne
regelungen einiges an licht einiges an
schatten im rahmen einer rede zeit bin
ich nur auf ein paar wenige ausgewählte
eingehen
zum vergleich der krankenhäuser unter
anderem das sollte seine pflege
quotienten und die zusammensetzung des
über die und die zusammensetzung des
pflegepersonals verpflichten
veröffentlicht werden
klingt erstmal gut denn es bringt licht
ins dunkel und kann den bestehenden
krassen pflegenotstand in den
krankenhäusern offenbaren das sichtbar
machen eines notstands ist allerdings
noch lang
die identisch mit der beseitigung des
notstands und in einem wettbewerblichen
umfeld in dem die krankenhäuser nach dem
willen der ihrer politik agieren sollen
kann das schnell zu einem weiteren
wettbewerblichen instrument werden dafür
ist uns die frage des pflegenotstands in
den krankenhäusern jedoch zu wichtig
qualitätsvergleich in der stadt zu
nehmen und in der ambulanten versorgung
wir hatten es ihnen ja beim
krankenhausstruktur gesetz 2015 vorher
gesagt dass sie mit dem versuch die
vergütung der krankenhäuser an
indikatoren der ergebnisqualität
auszurichten schiffbruch erleiden werden
weil diese indikatoren nicht
rechtssicher ausgestaltet werden können
werden sie jetzt in form dieser
qualitäts zu und abschläge die damals
eingeführt worden sind sang und klanglos
abgeschafft immerhin haben wir recht
behalten
für das jetzt für das damals eigens
geschaffene institut hektik sollen jetzt
wohl neue aufgaben geschaffen werden
deshalb nun diese qualitätsvergleich
immerhin sind sie zunächst nicht erlös
relevant dass es erst mal gut in dem von
ihm geschaffenen wettbewerblichen umfeld
werden sie vermutlich dennoch in zukunft
die gerichte beschäftigen weil ärzte und
krankenhäuser die die schlecht bewertet
fühlen dagegen klagen werden
der nutzen für die gesundheitsversorgung
der menschen ist zu mindestens
zweifelhaft
kommen wir zu einem lichtblick das ist
das auf rechnungs verbot in notlagen
tarif der privaten krankenversicherung
privatversicherte in notlagen tarif
haben immer beitragsschulden weil sonst
wären sie nicht in diesen notlagen tarif
müssen sie zum arzt oder ins krankenhaus
haben diese gegen die versicherten einen
zahlungsanspruch die private
krankenversicherung müsste die
rechnungssumme an den versicherten
überweisen
nach geltendem recht kann sie diese aber
mit den bestehenden beitragsschulden
verrechnen
im ergebnis ist der mittellose
versicherte den leistungserbringern geld
schuldig erhält aber von der
versicherung keinen cent das ist
schlecht für die betroffenen weil sich
damit logischerweise in der
schuldenspirale befinden
aber es ist auch schlecht für die kraft
für die ärzte weil die natürlich hat
eben keinen anreiz haben solche
versicherte gut zu behandeln oder
schnell zu behandeln
die linke hat auf das problem schon vor
einiger zeit mit einem mann mit einer
kleinen anfrage aufmerksam gemacht nun
wird das durch durch der durch ein auf
rechnungs verbot und durch
direktabrechnung geändert man sieht
links wirkt
dabei will nicht verlassen dann noch
einmal etwas grundsätzlich so etwas
grundsätzlichen konnte kommen denn
immerhin geht es ja auch um die
weiterentwicklung der
gesundheitsversorgung in deutschland
insgesamt und da ist ja einiges zu
entwickeln
das hat nicht zuletzt die korona
pandemie wie ein brennglas offenbart
aber was ist denn mit den lesson learned
welche vorstellungen gibt es denn zur
weiterentwicklung auch in diesem hause
da gibt es auf dieser seite des hauses
den erkennbaren wunsch den bisherigen
marktwirtschaftlichen wettbewerbs und
profit orientierten kurs in der
gesundheitspolitik nicht nur
fortzusetzen sondern sogar noch zu
verschärfen
bei der fdp mit der einer klassischen
neoliberalen lösung privat vor staat
marktversagen ist im zweifel sogar immer
besser als staatsversagen
rechts daneben die gleiche denke mit
einer unappetitlichen völkischen
nationalistischen duftmarke versehen
eine politik für reiche deutsche
verbindet sich damit einer sehnsucht
nach dem deutschen reich auch in der
gesundheitspolitik bleibe kann ich da
nur sagen
in der mitte des hauses finden wir eher
ordoliberale ausrichtung in der
gesundheitspolitik mit einem vorgegeben
den ordnungsrahmen soll dann möglichst
viel dem markt und den marktakteuren
überlassen werden
die debatte geht dann um die
ausgestaltung des rahmens um die höhe
und die farbe der leitplanken aber nicht
um die grundsätzliche richtung und ich
sage voraus dass das womöglich auch die
schnittmenge sein kann die schwarz und
grün in der gesundheitspolitik in
zukunft verbindet und da werden sich
womöglich auch darauf einigen können die
sozialdemokratie befindet sich in einer
doppelten babylonische gefangenschaft
zum einen in einer ungeliebten großen
koalition in der sie sich zunehmend
unwohl fühlt und sich nun mehr und mehr
als opposition in der koalition versucht
wir haben gestern ein wunderbares
beispiel mit dem glas trinken klingbeil
erleben können
zum anderen wird sie die geister der
eigenen vergangenheit die geisterte
agenda politik nicht los aber immerhin
scheint für die verschüttete glaubt der
erinnerung an das sozialstaatsgebot des
grundgesetzes immer mal wieder und immer
öfters durch aber wer die zunehmende
privatisierung im gesundheitswesen nicht
hinnehmen will
wer weiter darauf besteht dass
krankenhäuser nicht dazu da sind gewinne
zu machen sondern menschen gesund zu
machen wir eine solidarische
paritätische gemeinwohlorientierte
finanzierung des gesundheitswesens für
ein gebot
des grundgesetzes hält wer den
pflegenotstand in den krankenhäusern und
in der altenpflege nicht verwalten will
oder für gott gegeben hält sondern ihn
beseitigen will
der oder die kommt an der linken nicht
vorbei denn sie ist die einzige partei
die in diesem haus uneingeschränkt für
eine solche weiterentwicklung der
gesundheit zu sorgen steht vielen dank
max täter in die kollegin maria klein
schmeink rhein main bündnis 90 die
grünen sehr geehrter herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen frau
dittmer hat eigentlich gerade den
richtigen ausdruck gewählt für dieses
gesetz was heute hier eingebracht wird
nämlich ist es ein gesetz was mehr einem
puzzle gleicht als das ist tatsächlich
dem anspruch gerecht wird
gesundheitsversorgung verbesserung zu
sein und das ist eine reine in eine
lange reihe von gesetzen wo wir häufig
60 70 verschiedenste änderungen haben wo
aber eines nicht erreicht wird nämlich
eine nachhaltige verbesserung der
versorgung und gleichzeitig aber auch
ein konzept wie wir mehr qualität mehr
nutzen für die patientinnen und
patienten tatsächlich verankern
das ist eines der probleme sie können
noch so viele baustellen im bereich der
qualitätssicherung aufmachen
qualitätsmanagement vorgaben machen
transparenz vorgaben machen wenn sie es
nicht schaffen diese einzubinden in
grundlegende reform sowohl bei der
krankenhausversorgung in allen sollen
dieser krankenhausversorgung bei der
krankenhausplanung bei der entgelt bei
dem entgeltsystem und bei den
investitionskosten dann werden sie nicht
dahin kommen dass sie tatsächlich gute
qualität in der versorgung sicherstellen
erstens zweitens
sie vernachlässigen all das was nötig
wäre um tatsächlich bei der
sektorübergreifenden versorgung weiter
zu kommen das klingt wie ein schlagwort
heißt aber für die patientinnen und für
die versicherten ein gesteine struktur
strukturierte koordinierte versorgung
vor ort absprachen zwischen den
leistungserbringern über die qualität
über das was da eigentlich passieren
wird vermeiden von doppel von
doppeluntersuchungen am besten gestützt
durch digitale und telemedizinische
instrumente das wäre der weg den wir
einschlagen müssen wo sie ich genau dass
sie bringen ist fraglich in diesem
gesetz so etwas wie eine dringend
überfällige notfallversorgung in einem
einzigen passus wo wir dann ein
gemeinsames erst erfassungssystem
vereinbaren zu runter zu brechen und
klein zu zu brechen das kann es nicht
sein wir brauchen dort eine grundlegende
reform und sie hatten das ja eigentlich
anerkannt dass diese grundlegende reform
nötig wäre
wo bleibt sie auf weiter strecke nichts
zu sehen
und wir fühlten dass an einigen stellen
weitermachen und das zeigt es geht nicht
weiter so dass wir nur über puzzleteile
arbeiten sondern wir müssen ein
gesamtbild von guter versorgung von
guter ambulanter und stationärer
versorgung in allen leistungsbereichen
koordiniert zwischen den verschiedenen
formen von stationärer ambulant von
pflege von psycho sozialer unterstützung
das müsste passiert passieren ortsnahe
zugänglich aber auch mit einer hohen
qualität in einem gestuften
versorgungssystem und genau das fehlt
als bild das zeichnen sie nicht und das
ist der mangel warum jeder jede dieser
einzelnen ansätze nichts werden kann es
bleiben einfach zu klein gestellt
schrauben und da müssen wir gegenhalten
mit einem neuaufbruch in der
gesundheitspolitik und der ist dringend
erforderlich
soweit maria klein schmeink leben
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
sprecherin für gesundheitspolitik die ja
unter anderem auch den antrag der grünen
zum gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung in
der laufenden debatte begründet hat da
geht es unter anderem auch um eine
bewertung nicht nur von krankenhäusern
zum beispiel sondern auch der leistungen
der versorgungsqualität von
krankenkassen
nächster redner von der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion ist dietrich mond
statt der ebenfalls mitglied im
gesundheitsausschuss ist sehr geehrter
herr präsident sehr geehrte
bundesminister sparen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
damen meine herren wir möchten mit
diesem gesetz zur weiterentwicklung der
gesundheitsversorgung eine höhere
qualität und transparenz bessere
leistungen und eine stärkere vernetzung
in der versorgung versicherte erreichen
mein dank geht an gesucht dann den
gesundheitsministerien sparen und sein
haus das trotz epidemische lage auch
andere wichtige dinge weiterentwickelt
werden und der weinberg erlauben sie die
bemerkung dass sie unseren geschätzten
fraktionsvorsitzende ralph brinkhaus mit
dem namen eines wenn auch bekannten
fernseh arztes ansprechen ist
hoffentlich kein qualitätsindex zu ihrer
gesundheitspolitik meine damen und
herren lassen sie mich einige punkte aus
dem entwurf hervorheben der entwurf
sieht beispielsweise vor dass die
vorgaben für die festlegung von
mindestmengen durch den gemeinsamen
bundesausschuss geschärft werden
der minister ist hier auch schon genauer
eingegangen meine damen und herren als
berichterstatter für diabetes und
adipositas liegt mir die vernetzung der
versorgung gerade in diesem bereich
besonders am herzen
die einführung eines strukturierten
behandlungsprogrammen dmp zur besseren
behandlung von menschen mit adipositas
ist vor diesem hintergrund ein erster
wichtiger schritt um ihnen zu
verdeutlichen wie wichtig und überfällig
ein solches programm ist dadurch an
dieser stelle und die frau kollegin
dittmer hatte auch schon darauf
hingewiesen wie ich finde auf die
absolut dramatischen zahlen in diesem
bereich hinweisen
meine damen und herren 15,4 prozent der
kinder und jugendlichen sind
übergewichtig fast 6
adipös 67 prozent der männer sind
übergewichtig davon 23 prozent adipös
53 prozent der frauen sind übergewichtig
davon 24 prozent adipös
mit einer leider steigenden tendenz in
allen geworden was für die kinder wie
ich finde besonders dramatisch ist
heute stehen menschen die unter
adipositas leiden einer medizinischen
unterversorgung gegenüber und nach
meiner feststellung sind sie das auch
die krankheit wird zu spät festgestellt
und an nur schleppend behandelt die
selbstverwaltung unterstützt eine
leitliniengerechte behandlung nicht
immer uneingeschränkt mit dem neuen dmp
sorgen wir dafür dass haus- und
fachärzte sowie kliniken besser vernetzt
werden sollten die patientinnen und
patienten die besten medizinischen
angebote aus der ambulanten und
stationären versorgung dauerhaft
dauerhaft ermöglichen wir durch das neue
programm das individuelle und
bedarfsgerechte therapien für alle
zugänglich werden außerdem wird durch
das dmp der anreiz geschaffen
entsprechende therapien
weiterzuentwickeln
meine damen und herren am dritten juli
2020 jahren mit diesem hohen haus die
nationale diabetes strategie beschlossen
die darin enthaltenen forderungen nach
der sicherstellung einer individuellen
multimodalen und interdisziplinären
versorgung von menschen mit adipositas
wird nun im gmp aufgegriffen das darf
allerdings nicht der letzte schritt sein
meine damen und herren ebenso
hervorzuheben ist dass mit diesem gesetz
die koordination in hospiz und palliativ
netzwerken weiter gefördert werden soll
krankenkassen sollen künftig unter
bestimmten voraussetzungen zuschüsse
zahlen sich gemeinsam mit kommunalen
trägern der daseinsvorsorge an dem
aufbau und der förderung von
bedarfsgerechten regionalen hospiz und
palliativ netzwerk beteiligen
das sichert und stärkt diese regionalen
netzwerke meine damen und herren genauso
wichtig ist das in § 65 ps gb 5
die ambulanten krebsberatungsstelle
zukünftig mit einer deutlich höheren
summe durch die krankenversicherung
gefördert werden
so wird das jährliche fördervolumen um
240 millionen erhöht die summe der
pauschalen förderung die weiterhin für
jeweils drei jahre belegt wird führt zu
einer verbesserten planungssicherheit
sie führt letztlich durch die
erleichterte gewinnung qualifizierten
personals zu einer dauerhaften und
zuverlässigen betrieb in diesen
beratungsstellen
meine damen und herren mit der
gesetzlichen regelung wird auch die
arbeit in den überlasteten
notfallambulanzen weiter optimiert es
wird ein einheitliches erst
einschätzungs verfahren für die
ambulante notfall behandlung im
krankenhaus eingeführt die anwendung
dieses verfahrens gilt künftig als
voraussetzung für die abrechnung
ambulanter notfall- leistungen und 6 ist
mir wichtig hier heute darauf
hinzuweisen dass wir mit der regelung in
§ 120 es gebe fünf den zugang zur termin
vermittlung durch die termin
servicestellen nach vorstellungen in der
notfallambulanz erleichtern eine
überweisung ist hier nach inkrafttreten
der gesetzlichen regelung nicht mehr
erforderlich meine damen und herren mit
diesem gesetz taktik koalition viele
wichtige dinge an die versorgung der
patienten wird weiter verbessert die
gesundheitliche versorgung wird im
eigentlichen wortsinn weiterentwickelt
ich werbe daher um zustimmung und freue
mich auf die kommende beratung vielen
dank anstatt von der cdu csu fraktion
hat ja auf die versorgungs maßnahmen in
sachen palliativ und hospizversorgung im
neuen gesetz hingewiesen
möglicherweise auch ein thema dem sich
jetzt die nächste rednerin wenn widmen
wird nicole westlich von der fdp sie ist
die pflegepolitische sprecherin nicola
flagge so die politikerin
[Applaus]
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen als freie demokraten begrüßen
wir die neuregelungen zur
palliativversorgung die dieser
gesetzentwurf vorsieht
für kinder und jugendliche wird endlich
eine eigenständige rahmenvereinbarung in
der versorgung durch ambulante
hospizdienste geschaffen
das schließt eine seit langem bestehende
lücke und das unterstützen wir
ausdrücklich
denn die bedürfnisse der familie spielen
hier in dieser extrem herausfordernden
situation eine ganz wichtige rolle
man stelle sich nur die besondere
belastung der eltern aber auch der
geschwisterkinder vor wenn sie abschied
vom eigenen kind und geschwister
teilnehmen müssen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
halten es für wichtig schwerstkranke und
sterbende menschen ganzheitlich in den
blick zu nehmen denn menschen am
lebensende leiden nicht nur körperlich
sie leiden auch an den seelischen folgen
ihrer unheilbaren krankheit ein würdiges
sterben erfordert nicht nur eine gute
medizinische und pflegerische versorgung
es braucht mehr
es braucht psychologin die den
sterbenden und seine angehörigen auf den
letzten metern begleiten
es braucht sozialarbeiter die in einer
sozialen in seinem die in einer solchen
ausnahmesituation die krebskranke mutter
unterstützen die versorgung ihrer
kleinen kinder zu regeln
daher ist es wichtig nicht nur ärzte und
pflegekräfte in den ambulanten
palliativteams einzusetzen wir sollten
auch darüber sprechen wie wir den
anspruch auf ambulante
palliativversorgung um den wichtigen
aspekt der psychosozialen begleitung
erweitern können
lassen sie mich noch etwas zur
gesundheitspersonal statistik sagen es
ist löblich transparenz für patientinnen
und patienten zu schaffen wenn es um die
frage nach der qualität der
pflegerischen versorgung im krankenhaus
geht aber liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der groko ihre sogenannte transparenz
ist lediglich eine zustandsbeschreibung
und noch lange keine antwort auf den
akuten personalmangel liebe frau dittmer
da fiel noch viele viele puzzleteile
wenn sie diesen wirklich bekämpfen
wollen dann müssen sie mehr tun als nur
stellen zu schaffen sie müssen diese
auch besetzen und ein schlüssel dafür
lebt in der pflegeausbildung die
pandemie fordert hier einen bösen tribut
das ärzteblatt berichtet dass aktuell
immer mehr junge menschen unter der
besonderen belastung ihrer ausbildung
abbrechen
meine damen und herren das ist ein
früher flexit den wir uns gar nicht
leisten können
doch wen wundert das wenn man sieht dass
minister sparen auszubildende auch noch
für die durchführung der schnelltests
abstellen will und dies zu lasten ihrer
ausbildung die pandemie bedingt oft
genug hinten ansteht sieht so etwa die
neue wertschätzung in der pflege aus das
ist ausdruck einer pflegepolitik die
erst viel verspricht und dann ganz wenig
lieferte dennoch der vorgelegte
gesetzentwurf enthält gute ansätze und
ich freue mich auf die weitere beratung
vielen dank ein versöhnendes wort von
nicole westig immerhin eine oberste
vertreterin der oppositionsfraktion der
fdp pflegepolitische sprecherin zum
vorliegenden gesetzentwurf der
bundesregierung
die mund nasen abdeckung bild jetzt
brauchen sie nicht mehr aber und während
ich ihm sage ermahnt der
bundestagspräsident die bunt und nasen
abdeckung zu benutzen auch hier im
plenarsaal gesetzentwurf der
bundesregierung steht zur debatte
weiterentwicklung der
gesundheitsversorgung nächste rednerin
martina stammt von der spd sie ist die
patientenbeauftragte ihrer fraktion
kollegen unser gesundheitssystem muss im
angesicht der bestehenden
herausforderungen immer wieder
reformiert und weiterentwickelt werden
das ist ein wiederkehrender prozess denn
ein perfektes system gibt es nicht und
wird es auch nicht geben
die corina grunder pandemie hat uns alle
hier im haus in einem absoluten
ausnahmezustand versetzt
und das hat dazu geführt dass so manche
gesundheitspolitische zielsetzung
abseits des akuten krisenmanagements auf
der agenda nach hinten gerutscht ist
dabei zeigt uns gerade die pandemie dass
wir die übergeordneten ziele wie
qualität transparenz und eine
verbesserte vernetzung des
gesundheitssystems niemals aus den augen
verlieren dürfen
denn von erreichen dieser ziele hängt ab
wie krisensicher und zukunft fest unser
gesundheitssystem morgen sein wird mit
dem gesetz zur weiterentwicklung der
gesundheitsversorgung geben wir dem
system noch mal einen echten schub nach
vorne und dieses gesetz man höre und
staune enthält 34 wesentliche maßnahmen
die gut sinnvoll und in teilen auch
dringend notwendig sind aus zeitgründen
kann ich mir an dieser stelle nur auf
drei maßnahmen die ich entweder für
besonders wichtig halten oder bei denen
wir noch änderungsbedarf sehen
fangen wir mit dem modell klauseln für
die ausbildung in der hypo therapie
logotherapie und physiotherapie an
es kann nicht sein
dass die akademisierung beziehungsweise
teil akademisierung weiter auf die lange
bank geschoben wird die verlängerung der
modell klauseln bis 2026 erschwert den
universitäten und fachschulen völlig
ohne not die arbeit und leider auch zur
verschärfung des fachkräftemangels in
diesem gesundheitsfachberufen bei weil
potenzielle bewerber natürlich
verunsichert sind obendrein wird den
studierenden die akademische
weiterentwicklung verwehrt und die
finanzierungssituation an den
universitäten bleibt ebenfalls auf jahre
ungeklärt klare perspektiven minister
sehen anders aus
wenn man dann noch hört was manche
modellprojekten teilweise seit mehr als
zehn jahren laufen und konstant positiv
evaluiert werden kann man schon noch den
kann man nur noch den kopf schütteln wir
unsere fraktion fordern deshalb eine
begrenzung der verlängerung bis maximal
2024 und ein klares bekenntnis zur
akademisierung in der kommenden
legislatur berlin
eine weitere maßnahme die mir sehr am
herzen liegt ist der reform des notlagen
tarifs in der pkv
viele von ihnen wissen ich bin noch im
petitionsausschuss und was ich dazu
immer lese da wird es einem wirklich
manchmal angst und bange und ich sage
wenn wir eine solidarische
gesundheitsversicherung für alle hätten
dann müssten wir uns mit solchen fragen
nicht herumschlagen
aber bei allen ist eben der pfad der
erkenntnis noch nicht beschritten und
deshalb müssen wir uns auflösen solcher
probleme konzentrieren
durch die jetzige reform verhandeln wie
er ein auf rechnungs verbot von
leistungskosten und beitragsschulden in
notlagen tarif der pkv und so bewahren
wir die menschen die sowieso schon
finanziell angeschlagen sind im notlagen
tarif davor dass sie mit weiteren hohen
kosten konfrontiert werden und das ist
auch bitter nötig denn die entwicklung
zeigt die privat versicherten die in
notlagen tarif sind bleiben immer länger
dort das ist ein alarmzeichen für uns
alle weil sie eben finanziell nicht mehr
auf die beine kommen
und deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir
jetzt behandlungskosten mit dem beitrag
schuldner der pkv errechnet dass die
verrechnet werden lösen wir dieses
problem dass wir da einen riegel
vorschieben
zu guter letzt möchte ich noch mal drauf
eingehen wir sind sehr froh dass wir
endlich geld in die hand nehmen dass die
möglichkeit zur vereinbarung von
rahmenverträgen in der ambulanten hospiz
versorgung für kinder und jugendliche
endlich in diesem bereich deutlich
gestärkt wird jeder euro der in eine
gute palliativmedizinische betreuung
sowohl für erwachsene als auch für
kinder fließt ist gut investiertes geld
vielen dank martina schlampig von der
spd patientenbeauftragte sie hatte unter
anderem auch den notlagen tarif in der
gesetzlichen in der privaten
entschuldigung der privaten
krankenversicherung angesprochen da geht
es vor allen dingen menschen die die
krankenvollversicherung die private
krankenversicherung nicht mehr zahlen
können was man zum beispiel kleinere
selbständige und bündnis 90/die grünen
nächste rednerin kirsten kaputter
sprecherin für gesundheitsförderung
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
die taktzahl der gesetzes maschinerie im
hause sparen ist weiterhin sehr hoch
aber eine maschine die viel energie
frisst laut rumpelt und am ende leider
nur produkte mit sehr geringer
halbwertszeit ausspuckt die ist nicht
geeignet um die notwendigen
transformationen in unserem
gesundheitssystem wirklich anzugehen
[Applaus]
wieder sind für die meisten patientinnen
und patienten hier viel zu gering
im gesundheitsversorgung
weiterentwicklungsgesetz dem tv wg
fehlen weiter die großen linien die
vorgeschlagenen reformen werden immer
kleinteiliger und sind zum teil wirklich
problematisch ihre groß angekündigte
neuordnung der notfall reform wurde auf
ein umstrittenes standardisiertes
verfahren zur erster einschätzung im
krankenhaus eingedampft von dem wir noch
nicht mal wissen ob es nicht vielleicht
sogar die patientin paar sicherheit
gefährdet dabei ist eine echte
sektorübergreifende notfall reform
dringend erforderlich und prävention
gesundheitsförderung beschränkte sich im
wesentlichen auf die unterstützung von
kurorten
dabei müssen wir endlich die
gesundheitsförderung in den
alltagswelten etablieren und die
seelische gesundheit die hätte deutlich
mehr aufmerksamkeit verdient wir sehen
doch wie gerade jetzt in der panini
viele menschen viele kinder und
jugendliche sehr unter druck geraten
menschen mit schweren psychischen
erkrankungen leiden gerade ganz
besonders stark schaffen sie doch bitte
endlich einen anspruch auf ambulante
komplexleistung für schwer psychisch
kranke damit eine abgestimmte behandlung
etwa aus ergotherapie ambulante
psychiatrische pflege sozialtherapie
auch im ambulanten setting ermöglicht
wird der bedarf ist riesig und schaffen
sie diesen anspruch auch besonders für
kinder und jugendliche denn wenn
erkrankungen bei kindern übersehen
werden dann drohen sie im
erwachsenenalter zu qualifizieren eine
gut abgestimmte frühzeitige
multiprofessionelle versorgung erspart
den betroffenen lange
handlungsfähige und leidenswege gerade
die korona pandemie kann unsere
wahrnehmung für unsere seelische
gesundheit noch einmal schärfen aus der
pandemie lernen heißt eben auch zu
lernen dass wir den schnellen zugang zu
passgenauen psychiatrische und
psychotherapeutische versorgung brauchen
ich hoffe dass wir einige dieser punkte
noch durch die beratungen im ausschuss
aufnehmen können und somit wirklich zur
verbesserung von patientinnen und
patienten kommen ich danke ersten konter
von bündnis 90/die grüne sie ist
sprecherin für gesundheitsförderung in
ihrer fraktion voraussichtlich
drittletzte redner zur laufenden debatte
über die weiterentwicklung in der
gesundheitsversorgung ist lothar
riebsamen von der cdu csu fraktion auch
er mitglied im gesundheitsausschuss
sogar auch präsident liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen das
bundesgesundheitsministerium der
minister hat seit einem jahr alle hände
voll zu tun um die korona krise zu
bewältigen
gleichwohl wird uns heute ein gesetz
vorgelegt das eine vielzahl von themen
anspricht die vorder lohner krise
wichtig waren und die auch nach der
korona krise wichtig seien würden
insofern ist dies keine reste rampe
sondern es zeigt dass auch in der krise
im maschinenraum des bmg hat gearbeitet
wird und dafür gebührt dem bmg dank und
anerkennung in diesem gesetz stehen die
patientinnen und patienten im
vordergrund dann wenn sie ins
krankenhaus müssen dann wenn sie zum
arzt müssen oder wenn sie vielleicht am
ende ihres lebens auch eine hospiz oder
palliativversorgung in anspruch nehmen
müssen was tut sich konkret
aus sicht der krankenhäuser geht es um
qualität
es geht um strukturen und es geht um
transparenz qualität ist immer schon
angelegt im sgb fünf qualitätssicherung
nach innen und nach außen und auch 2016
haben wir das mit dem
krankenhausstruktur gesetz das thema
qualität noch einmal deutlich adressiert
mit qualitäts verträgen mit zu und
abschlägen das eine hat sich bewährt
dass andere nicht so ist das bei
versuchen und nun wird das gestellt was
sich bewährt hat nämlich die qualitäts
verträge hier werden zusätzliche
möglichkeit möglichkeiten geschaffen
wird zusätzliche dynamik hineingebracht
in dem auch mindestvolumen vorgesehen
wurden vom budget die in diese qualitäts
verträge hineinfließen es wird fahrt
aufgenommen da durch und deswegen ist
dies auch eine wichtige sache und ein
wichtiges weiteres instrument sind die
mindestmengen es ist doch völlig klar
dass dann wenn ein komplizierter
eingriff notwendig ist routine
auch dafür vorausgesetzt werden muss
routine und auch strukturen personeller
natur auch technischer natur
und genau da liegt auch die
herausforderung dies zu schaffen diese
strukturen zu schaffen und bei qualität
kann es dann auch keine ausnahmen geben
und deswegen wurden auch die ausnahmen
an der stelle abgeschafft aber wie
gesagt die sind auch herausforderungen
insbesondere wenn es um den ländlichen
raum geht es kann natürlich dann nicht
sein dass man zwei stunden in die
nächste uni klinik fahren muss hier
kommt drauf an gott wo die strukturen
nicht vorhanden
diese neu zu schaffen dafür braucht es
den bund mit dem strukturfonds dafür
braucht es die länder
und dafür braucht es natürlich auch die
investitionskosten förderung und die
krankenhaus bedarfsplanung der länder
frau scheint schweigt wenn ich in baden
württemberg mir das angucken kann ich
nicht erkennen dass dort großartig
krankenhaus bedarfsplan getrieben wird
es hat sich vieles zum positiven
verändert aber nur weil es die träger
gemacht haben und nicht weil sich das
land an der stelle
besonders ausgezeichnet hätte das muss
ich an der stelle schon auch mal
deutlich sagen und zu guter letzt geht
es auch um das thema transparent
transparenz die patientinnen und
patienten müssen einfach in der lage
sein und in die lage versetzt werden
sich ein bild zu machen was sie im
krankenhaus oder in der arztpraxis
erwartet und auch an der stelle kann man
weitere verbesserungen erzielen und es
wird mit diesem gesetz erreicht und zwar
dadurch dass die datenbasis zukünftig
auf breitere beine gestellt wird dass
die grundlage die grundlage werden
digitale befragungs instrumente seien
dies bisher schlicht und ergreifend
nicht gab die werden zukünftig zur
verfügung stehen und die patienten
müssen auch in die lage versetzt worden
zu prüfen ob sie gut auch pflegerisch
versorgt worden in einem krankenhaus und
deswegen ist es richtig und es ist in
diesem gesetz so angelegt dass der
pflegepersonal quotient öffentlich
gemacht wird dass jeder patient sehen
kann bevor ins krankenhaus geht würde
ich in diesem krankenhaus pflegerisch
gut versorgt oder nicht und auch das ist
ein großer fortschritt
mehrere kolleginnen und kollegen mit
diesem gesetz wird mehr qualität mehr
transparenz geschaffen
wir werden in ausschuss diese fragen
tiefer bewerten und diskutieren ich
freue mich auch die beratungen im
ausschuss und werbe heute schon dafür
dass wir diesem gesetz zustimmen es ist
ein gutes und wichtiges gesetz für die
patientinnen und patienten in unserem
land herzlichen dank lothar riebsamen
von der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion die
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer ich weiß es
jetzt schon darauf hin dass wir um 10
uhr 15 im bundestag hier in unserem
linearen unserem normalen
fernsehprogramm verlassen werden
die pressekonferenz des
bundesgesundheitsministers sich
einsparen der jedoch im bundestag ist
und des präsidenten des robert koch
instituts und agiler live zu übertragen
10 15 im moment läuft die debatte noch
zur gesundheitsversorgung sechs
vertreter der flut von der spd
eingebracht aber ich will das kommt ihm
auch noch einmal aufgreifen auch weil
ich fand dass einige bemerkungen zu den
puzzleteilen sagen wir den sinn des
bistums nicht ganz erfasst haben denn
kein mensch würde puzzleteile auflegen
wenn da nicht auch ein gesamtbild vor
augen hätten über ein puzzle möchte und
wer würde schon gar nicht kann würde
schon gar nicht puzzleteile sozusagen
möglicherweise sogar verändern oder
ergänzen wenn man nicht wüsste dass sie
in das bild hinein passen also macht
dieses gesetz sind wie sorgen damit
dafür dass das gesamtbild stimmiger wird
wir sorgen auch damit dafür dass
bestimmte aspekte aufgegriffen und
vielleicht auch kaputte puzzleteile
repariert werden die kollegin kappa
grund hat völlig zu recht angesprochen
komme ich gleich auch noch mal drauf
dass wir die frage der seelischen
gesundheit an dieser stelle auch sehr
deutlich noch einmal betrachten müssen
herr kollege gestellt
zu fragen der fdp ja wieder angefangen
aber mit vielen dank halten wird ist die
frage zu lassen da sie das bild in den
puzzleteilen weiter vertiefen
stimmen sie mir zu das wenig sinn ein
puzzle anzufangen wenn viele puzzleteile
fehlen also ehrlich gesagt kann man
durchaus ein puzzle anfangen puzzleteile
fehlen da man schon im kopf hat wo man
sie her bekommen kann und wie man dafür
sorgen kann dass man am ende wenn man
alle puzzleteile zusammen hat auch ein
wirklich wunderschönes gesamtbild hat
und genau vor dem hintergrund stehen wir
und wir sorgen jetzt dafür dass die
puzzleteile zusammen kommen und dass am
ende ein schönes gesamtbild gibt und
dann hoffe ich werden sie auch dem
gesetz und uns zustimmen vielen dank
herr kollege
so jetzt kommen ja auch vom puzzle ein
bisschen sechs sonst wird das hier der
falsche vortrag glaube ich dass ich
gleich gerne machen sollten also ganz
wichtig ist es auch dass wir mit diesem
gesetz die seelische gesundheit nicht
ins auge nehmen
da gebe ich recht da gebe es noch eine
menge teile an denen wir dringend etwas
tun müssen
einige sind schon angesprochen worden
ich will das noch mal ergänzen auch um
das was ich eigentlich gehofft hatte und
erwartet hätte im gesetz nämlich dass
wir auch was umsätzen aus der expertise
die wir bezogen auf kinder aus
suchtkranken und familien oder familien
mit psychischen belastungen haben wir
diese kinder brauchen da sind wir auch
bei komplex leistungen übrigen brauchen
ganz wichtige leistungen
das wäre hier möglich gewesen schon mal
puzzleteile aufzugreifen und das bild zu
vervollständigen damit wir helfen können
das hätte ich mir gewünscht und
vorgestellt
da werden wir vielleicht auch noch mal
drüber reden müssen froh bin ich dass
wir ein puzzleteil reparierenden frei in
der frage der seelischen gesundheit denn
es ist ja nicht so ganz so dass wir bei
den komplex leistungen nichts machen im
bereich der ambulant da haben wir schon
auch was im auftrag gegeben ja kann ich
darüber streiten die großen wir haben
uns im augenblick erkennen die
zielrichtung geben zur für kinder und
jugendliche müssen wir es noch
verschärfen aber so noch einmal druck
hinter und wir waren uns einig wir
wollten die psychiatrischen
institutsambulanz an der stelle auch mit
im boot sehen und da haben wir
tatsächlich ein puzzleteil kreiert das
nicht ganz sagen wir mal korrekt war
nicht ganz vernünftig funktioniert hat
vielleicht
der abgebrochene schönen dank dass
dieses portal repariert werden und die
psychiatrische institutsambulanz jetzt
nicht nur sinnvoll einbezogen werden
sondern auch bei der finanzierungsfrage
in richtiger form berücksichtigt werden
nämlich dass die neu geschaffene
finanzierung auch für die
psychiatrischen institutsambulanz gilt
aber nicht das gesamtsystem damit
verändert werden soll
das ist glaube ich eine ganz ganz
wichtige feststellung und klarstellung
an dieser stelle ich würde mir sehr
wünschen dass wir da an vielen punkten
noch weiter kommen gerade was die frage
der komplexbehandlung angeht aber auch
was die frage des managements angeht da
haben wir auch schon glaube ich eine
gute regelung gemacht nämlich dass
bereits bei dem krankenhaus aufenthalt
der weg in die ambulanz geebnet werden
kann erstkontakte auch mit dem
psychotherapeutinnen und
psychotherapeuten stattfinden können es
macht aber keinen sinn diese nur in den
kliniken stattfinden zu lassen
da gebe es auch wichtigen bedarf dafür
zu sorgen dass das auch im ambulanten
bereich dann stattfinden kann damit das
wirkt und vernünftig ist
das gleiche gilt auch für menschen die
etwa mit trauma folgen zu kämpfen haben
auch da brauchen wir noch dringend
weitere und andere ansätze vielleicht
können wir auch da in diesem gesetz ein
wenig weiter gucken aber bei all dem was
wir weiter gucken können
das gesetz bietet viele gute ansätze die
frage der ansätze die wir im bereich der
menschen haben wo wir uns um
palliativmedizin wo wir uns um den
hospiz bereich kümmern sind sehr gut
sind vernünftig ich komme aus einem
bereich in dem koordinierung schon gar
nicht so schlecht funktioniert ich weiß
aber nach gab es immer an der
finanzierung genau dieser frage dass wir
an dieser stelle anpacken ist ein
wichtiger weg insgesamt ein gutes gesetz
ich glaube wir können und damit komme
ich zurück zu den puzzleteilen noch ein
bisschen was dabei puzzeln und dann
haben auch ein ganz tolles bild und auch
der kollege schöneburg wird begeistert
sein davon gehe ich aus ich freue mich
auf die weiteren beratungen
dankeschön es folgt in der beratung hier
im plenarsaal des bundestages zum
gesetzt
gesundheitsfürsorge und die
weiterentwicklung des unterhalts
versorgung der voraussichtlich letzte
redner stefan pischinger von der
cdu/csu-fraktion mitglied im bund im
gesundheitsausschuss und von beruf wie
viele redner in dieser debatte arzt ich
kann mich noch sehr gut an die rede von
hier entspannt zum bundeshaushalt 2020
hier im plenum erinnern das war im
november 2009 10
damals konnte der gesundheitsminister
mit stolz verkünden in den
zurückliegenden 20 monaten 20 gesetze
auf den weg gebracht zu haben
und mit diesen gesetzen konnten wir
nicht nur den alltag der patientinnen
und patienten und mitarbeiter im
gesundheitswesen spürbar verbessern
sie haben damit auch unsere
gesundheitssystem weiterentwickelt und
an zahlreichen stellen nachgebessert
heute meine damen und herren knapp 15
monate später ist diese arbeit aber
natürlich noch nicht abgeschlossen im
gegenteil wenige monate nach verkündung
dieses zwischenziel hat uns die krone
pandemie mit voller wucht getroffen und
unser land denn an der schwersten
gesundheits krisen der neuzeit gestürzt
trotzdem haben sowohl die
bundesregierung als auch das parlament
in den vergangenen monaten gezeigt wir
sind auch unter den ungewohnten und
herausfordernden bedingungen der
weltweiten pandemie weiterhin voll
arbeitsfähig
herr kollege filzinger würde ich eine
der fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen
zwischen frage gestellt sehr gerne
die kollegen haben
ja zunächst vielen dank dass sie die
frage zugelassen herr kollege billiger
die haben ja grad die großartige
leistungsbilanz des
bundesgesundheitsministers in den
vergangenen monaten und jahren gelobt
mich würde interessieren sie hatten hier
in einer rede am 12 10 20 18
wo es um eine ähnlich komplexe artikel
gesetzgebung ging angekündigt dass es
eine grundlegende notfall reform für die
notfallversorgung in deutschland geben
würde ist der vorliegende
gesetzesentwurf diese angekündigte
grundlegende notfall reform oder dürfen
wir damit rechnen dass der hat ja schon
ausgearbeitete referenten wurf zu einem
ähnlichen thema noch eingebracht wird
also herr kollege damen mich freut dass
gerade die frage aus den reihen von
bündnis 90 die grünen kommen nämlich ich
muss sie darauf hinweisen dass gerade
die länder die notfallversorgung massiv
eingedampft haben und ich möchte auch
hinweisen dass die grünen und den
meisten landesregierung vertreten sind
also wenn sie organisieren dann machen
wir
[Applaus]
vor dem hintergrund der krise müssen wir
deshalb jetzt dafür sorgen dass unser
gesundheitssystem auch künftig
herausforderungen standhält
mit dem gesetz zur weiterentwicklung der
gesundheitsversorgung kommen wir diesem
ziel wieder einen schritt näher
durch mehr qualität und transparenz in
der gesundheitsversorgung von bessere
leistungen für versicherte
vieles von dem was sie mit dem
vorliegenden gesetzentwurf regeln wurde
von meinem vorredner bereits
angesprochen deshalb möchte ich mich
nach folgen gerne auf drei punkte
konzentrieren
der erste punkt betrifft die kinder und
jugendhospiz arbeit zu stärken der
ambulanten kinderhospizdienste muss für
diesen bereich künftig eine gesonderte
rahmenvereinbarung geschlossen werden
damit können wir den besonderen belangen
der versorgung von kindern und
jugendlichen in zukunft noch besser
gerecht werden
aber das wird in der summe nicht reichen
der bundesverband kinderhospiz hat
ausgerechnet dass allein die arbeit der
ambulanten kinderhospizdienste mit zwölf
millionen euro jährlich unterfinanziert
ist insofern begrüßt sich zwar dass wir
mit dem tv wg die aufmerksamkeit wieder
auf dieses wichtige thema lenken
ausreichend sind die maßnahmen aber
leider noch nicht hier gilt es in der
zukunft auch finanziell nachzubessern
denn nur so können wir eine wirklich
nachhaltige verbesserung der
lebensqualität von schwerstkranken
kindern und jugendlichen erreichen
der nächste punkt betrifft das thema
übergewicht und adipositas mit dem tv wg
beauftragen wir den gemeinsamen
bundesausschuss dazu ein neu
strukturiertes behandlungsprogramm zu
entwickeln
grundsätzlich begrüße ich diesen vorstoß
für mich geht ein solches disease
management programm aber leider noch
nicht weit genug denn wenn die patienten
erst einmal deutlich übergewichtig sind
ist es ja schon zu spät also müssen wir
eigentlich viel früher ansetzen
die fehl- und überernährung der
bevölkerung kann flächendeckend nur
durch eine kombination aus
leitliniengerecht der primärprävention
und der gezielten behandlung von
übergewicht und adipositas erfolgen
die strukturellen voraussetzungen für
solche behandlungskonzept da haben wir
schon
sie müssen nun aber auch endlich
so gkv leistung werden zuletzt möchte
ich noch auf ein thema eingehen dass mir
als berichterstatter sehr wichtig ist
und zwar auch das thema raus rauch
aufstieg noch immer sterben allein in
deutschland jedes jahr 127 tausend
menschen an den folgen des rauchens
trotzdem sind arzneimittel zur
rauchentwöhnung weiterhin von der
versorgung durch die gitter vor
ausgeschlossen
das muss sich ändern leitliniengerecht
daraufhin kühlungs angebote müssen
endlich zur regelleistung werden nur so
können wir auch die menschen erreichen
die aus all dies aus eigener kraft nicht
schaffen aus der sucht auszusteigen
deshalb werde ich mich im rahmen der
anstehenden debatten zum tv wg
ausdrücklich dafür einsetzen den
ausschluss der kostenübernahme für eine
rauchentwöhnung aus dem sgb 5 zu
streichen
in diesem sinne wünsche ich uns gute
beratung zum gesetzesentwurf vielen dank
so das war die erste lesung zum
gesetzentwurf über die weiterentwicklung
in der gesundheitsversorgung